welcome welcome welcome welcome
to our today program Bible q a this as
I'm finding out is one of our favorite
programs not our favorite approach but
your favorite programs because everybody
has so many questions I have so many
questions but we have three ho we have
three people here today that are going
to assist us in answering your questions
first of all I just want to introduce
each one we have Daniel Perrin Daniel
Works in pastoral such such a blessing
you know we have uh Pastor James
Rafferty director of discipleship good
to be here oh it's always good to see
you and then we have my precious little
wife here this is Shelly Quinn welcome
Shelly oh it's good to be here with you
it's good to see you uh
because these are your questions you're
probably wondering well how do I get
those questions to you so I'm going to
tell you right now how we do that if you
are going to text your questions in it's
618-228-3975 let me repeat that
618-228-3975 perhaps you would rather
email a man if you choose to email them
in it's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
Bible QA at
3abn.tv and then if you're going to use
Instagram which more people are using it
all the time it's at the at symbol 3abn
underscore official one more time at
3abn underscore official
I have a scripture that I want to read
to you okay this is just one of my
favorite scriptures and it's found in
Psalms 119 105.
your word is a lamp to my feet and a
light to my path and then I like what it
says in in 103 how sweet are your words
to my taste sweeter than honey to my
mouth amen amen Precious Precious
sometimes we have a way of stumbling and
I just love to be able to say well JD
get back in the word it's a lamp to my
feet a light to my path amen
uh with Shelley would you have our
opening prayer oh absolutely
loving father we come before you in the
name of Jesus we are so thankful for
Jesus Christ your Holy Spirit and your
word These Are Spiritual words
spiritually discerned so father we ask
in the name of Jesus that you would send
your Holy Spirit now
and speak your word through us give us
Clarity of thought
and Lord may we all be blessed as we
lift up Jesus High we love you we thank
you and we ask this in the name of Jesus
amen amen
as I mentioned a while ago we're going
to take 12 questions each question have
a three-minute answer except for just a
one or two or three and they'll have a
four-minute answer so let's start with
you Daniel
who do you confess your sins to the
father or the son and this is Lisa from
New Jersey that sent this in Lisa the
invitation to confess our sins to a
loving heavenly father is such a gift
and I'm grateful that you are embracing
it we serve one God God is one and
whether we address Jesus the son as
people did while he was on the earth or
whether we address the father what is
spoken to one member of the godhead is
in the hearing of each member but each
member of the godhead has a distinct
work and we need each one and we should
do our best to pray with an
understanding and knowledge of what God
is doing for us so there's a clear
statement in Scripture that we find in
Ephesians chapter 2 verse 18 that says
for through him speaking of Jesus here
for through Jesus we both have access by
one Spirit to the father
and so through Jesus he speaks of
himself as the door and the gate for the
sheep and so we approach the father
through Jesus by uh by the power of the
spirit giving us wisdom and the ability
to confess our sins while Jesus was
himself was not confessing sins even in
his life on Earth he did direct his
prayers to the father and then he
instructed us to do the same we have
that the Lord's Prayer there in Matthew
chapter 6 where we address Our Father
who is in heaven
in John chapter 16 verses 26 and 27
referring to the father Jesus says this
in that day you will ask asking the
father in my name I do not say that you
and not say to you that I shall pray the
father for you for the father himself
loves you isn't that one of the best
things to hear and so Jesus says you
will come to the father in my name now
we know that Jesus does have the power
to forgive sins he says to that
paralytic he says son I tell you your
sins are forgiven but even Jesus they're
in John 6 38 says that I do nothing of
my own authority but only what the
father wills and so we approach the
father through the power of Jesus and if
we go to the Old Testament the name of
Jesus was unknown there but Jesus is
represented in the lamb sacrifice and so
how do we approach the father it is
through the blood Hebrews 9 22 says that
without the blood there is no remission
of sin
and so we come to God's presence and as
you did that in the Old Testament
Tabernacle or the temple you would take
the blood of the confessed sins and you
would then sprinkle him on the horns of
that altar the golden altar of incense
right before the veil and then your
prayers are mingled with uh your your
prayers Rising as incense mingled with
the blood of Christ into God's presence
and so we know that God is full of
compassion and he hears but when you
pray to the father praise his love for
you and speak of Jesus speak of his
sacrifice speak of his ministry speak of
his love for you and claim by faith the
power that is in his name and then ask
for the guiding of the holy spirit so we
pray to the father in the name of Jesus
by the power of the holy spirit amen
thank you Daniel
Pastor James
why don't we hear more about what to do
when the Sunday law comes why don't we
hear about it in our churches and on
three ABN so that we can be sure are
secure no one talks about what's coming
and what to do in detail can you explain
why or how to find it and this is
Crystal from Paradise California all
right crystal from Paradise California I
can relate I live in California myself
Central California so it may be that
people talk about it and what to do
but we aren't aware so let's just cover
some Basics so one of the and we'll just
go in order here I'm going to do the
last one the most important one last the
first one is I think country living is a
good thing uh it would be good for us to
get out of large cities as much as we
can even permanently if possible learn
how to grow your own food to be a little
bit independent have spiritually
defensible space from the immoral
influences of the world commune with God
in nature go out for hikes go out
camping get away from the city if you
live in the city or work in the city get
away from the city as much as possible
even move out of the cities and speak
let God speak to you of his of his
creative works let him speak to you
through nature this is especially
important if you have children in fact
I'd encourage you if you have children
do all of you all that you can to get
out of the city permanently
so they can be surrounded with an
atmosphere that is more spiritual the
second is character development to
prepare for the Sunday law to prepare
for the crisis ahead of us
we need to be living away from the
cities just for the purpose of
developing our character it's not this I
live in the city so I'm going to be
saved it's I live away from the hustle
and the bustle and the crime and the
violence and the influences so I can
develop a character spend more time with
the Lord be more connected with him and
less distracted by the things of this
world so it's very important we're told
in second Corinthians 3 18 by beholding
we become changed Philippians 4 8 we
need to hold those things that are true
and lovely and just and have good report
but then finally I think the most
important thing that everyone should be
talking about in preparation for the
Sunday law that through here at 3ab and
talk about all the time to prepare
people for the Sunday law even though we
may not make those two these two
connections but I'll make them now is we
need to focus on Christ right in
Revelation 14 verse 4 it says that the
special instruction of God's people in
the end of time is that they follow the
lamb wherever he goes amen and that's in
the wake of the Sunday lord they're
following Jesus so we're not saved by
country living you're right we're not
saved by having a garden why not even
say it by character development we're
saved by Christ and his righteousness
and when we follow Jesus all these other
things come out of that so none of us
are going to be lost who placed their
entire trust in Jesus even if they're
still living in the city some of God's
people may be in prison in the end of
time but as long as they put their faith
in Christ just like the thief on the
cross did you know here he was he was a
prisoner he was on death row but he was
able to say Lord remember me when you
come into thy kingdom and Jesus said I'm
telling you right now this day the day
that I'm curious about I'm telling you
you will be with me in paradise and
that's what we want we want to hear
those words from Christ that will be
with him that we're assured that we'll
be with him no matter what the crisis is
that we face and this is going to happen
as we follow the lamb wherever he goes
amen amen thank you amen
Shelley can you please explain second
Corinthians 5 10-15 and this is Sherry
from Pennsylvania
well Sherry in context Paul is speaking
about being ambitious
for God's purposes and striving
earnestly to please him and works of
ministry so let's look at Second
Corinthians 5 10.
he's goes on and he says for we must all
appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ that each one may receive the
things done in the body according to
what he has done whether good or bad now
we're saved by grace through faith Paul
is not speaking here
of the Judgment of our Eternal
destination we have the Judgment seat of
Christ and then we have the great white
Throne judgment that we're going to get
into later
but what he's speaking here is to
Christians and he's saying we're all
going to answer for what we've done
while we're in the flesh so this is not
the great white Throne Judgment of
Revelation 20 that happens after the
first resurrection so that will happen
at the second so when he's talking about
Deeds whether good or bad I don't know
that it's so much
good or evil I think it's useless futile
Deeds is what my take on this is
you know there's either we're doing
because Paul is speaking about doing
things to fulfill God's purposes in
Ministry and let's say that
um you're doing something that has no
Eternal value it's
just useless let's say when you get on
Facebook rather than posting a scripture
to encourage somebody what are you doing
are you criticizing are these are the
things that even as Christians we're
going to be judged by what we do First
Corinthians 3 12-15
Paul says if anyone Builds on this
Foundation he says I you know we've laid
the foundation and that Foundation is
Jesus Christ if you build on it with
gold silver precious stones okay those
are all good materials or wood hay and
straw each one's work will become clear
for the day we'll declare it because it
will be refilled by fire and the fire
will test each one's work what sort it
is if anyone's work which is built on it
endures he receives a reward if anyone's
work is burned he will suffer a loss but
he himself will be saved yet as Through
Fire you know when Jesus returns he says
in revelation 22 that he's going to come
back he says my reward is with me we are
standing there's a pre a judgment a
pre-investigative judgment that happens
before he returns for his righteous he
is determining what we've done whether
it was really to promote his purposes or
if it was just waste of time we need to
redeem our time amen thank you Shelly
okay Daniel this is your four minute one
okay four minute question
answer
please can you explain Daniel 12 11
through 12. and this is from zelia in
Clan Williams South Africa
all right this is a big question to
answer in four minutes I'll read the
text it's right here near the very end
of Daniel the whole book and from the
time that the daily sacrifice is taken
away and the abomination of desolation
is set up there shall be
1290 days blessed is he who Waits and
comes to the
1335 days
so I'm going to give you both a brief
answer and end with a Biblical principle
but if you want a fuller story go watch
salvation and symbol and signs and
you'll get all the way through to the
end and find an even Fuller answer there
the full answer is going to have some
multiple layers of explanation but the
time prophecies of Daniel are all set in
the context of a prophetic story so in
Daniel chapter 7 you have 1260 days
they're literal years and it's set in
the context of a little horn power that
is rampaging spiritually and physically
against God and his people the 2 300
evenings and mornings 2300 literal years
is in the context of the sacrificial and
Heavenly Ministry of Jesus and the
attack on that in the 70 weeks or the
490 years of chapter 9 of Daniel is set
in the context of events revolving
around the Messiah but right here in the
last chapter the 1290 and 1335 days are
in the context of chapter 12 verse 1.
where there shall at that time Michael
the great Prince stands up for
deliverance of God's people and there is
a time of trouble such as never was
and so we recognize that what we see
here is going to be a message to those
right here in the end in a final time of
trouble we recognize that in verse 10
there is uh this is a message to the
wise in verse 12 this is to those who
are waiting in verse 9 this is to those
who are who are looking for something to
be unsealed for longing for more
information and we also see here in this
chapter in verse 7 that this is under
the direction of Jesus himself we see
him there the same Jesus that we saw in
chapter 10 of Daniel as well and so
while these these uh time prophetic
periods are connected to Daniel 7 to 9.
this also has a message for people who
are waiting in the end time of conflict
so the 1260 days here from chapter 7 is
repeated here in verse 7 and the angel
already explained it there in chapter
seven so uh we know what that refers to
historically but this provides a basis
for helping us understand what's
happening here and so it confirms and
strengthens the dates that we understand
already from Daniel so when we take the
1290 and 1335 days and we lay them over
the 1260 days we recognize that they
they end at the same time the 1260 and
1290 and but so the 12 or 90 are going
to start a little bit earlier in the
1335 start along with them and so this
gives us a historical confirmation of
what we found we see a little time of
trouble beginning there in 508 when a
political and religious power unite and
the the state adds its power to
sponsored religion and giving giving
power to the papal organization and so
this paves the way then for a great time
of trouble that begins in 538 when
religious power has full civil authority
to destroy and this concludes that in
1798 when the papal power no longer has
its Authority and then there is a time
of Deliverance that is completed when 18
1943 and 1844 come along into full
knowledge of Revelation for those who
wait and get to the end of that the
understanding of Jesus and the work that
he is doing in the Heavenly Sanctuary
all right if that left you more
questions then you already had salvation
and symbols and signs the historical
events are completed in the past but it
provides a pattern for what you and I
will experience as we go through waiting
for this time of trouble we recognize
that there is going to be a small time
of trouble when State and religious
Powers unite Paving the way for a great
time of trouble when there will be
all-out war and death decree upon God's
people we see that in Revelation 13. to
be concluded finally by a time of
Deliverance and this lets us know as we
go into uh into events that are coming
there is a time of Deliverance the
biblical principle I'll save that for
the end amen amen that's it mouthful yes
James
why did God Force man to eat meat after
the flood he could have created more
vegetation to replace that which he
destroyed with the flood just like he
did when he created the world in the
beginning and this is from Mike in Red
Oak Texas that's a great question Mike I
mean God can perform Miracles I think
the main reason seems to be that God
needed to shorten the length of the
lifespan of Sinners just to be honest
with you in in order to avoid another
flood Calamity because men lived for so
many years we're talking Abraham I mean
Abraham Adam lived for over 900 years
and many of his contemporaries lived for
900 years and 800 years and 700 years
and all of those who turned away from
God had centuries to accumulate the
knowledge of wickedness and to educate
and pass it on to others and that
brought this world to a place where God
had to actually take it out and start
all over again in a very short time and
so I think part of God's purpose in
allowing man to eat the meat was to
shorten that lifespan because we know
after the flood when man started eating
meat that people lived a lot shorter
lives Abraham lived 175 which to us is
still a long time right and then you
have Moses living 120 years and then you
have what Joseph living 110 years at the
end of Exodus Genesis excuse me chapter
50 tells us that so when you think about
this you're you're realizing that God
had a purpose or a plan and he his
purpose and plan was to allow the
animals to go into the ark seven by
seven clean animals we read that in
Genesis chapter 2 2 excuse me Genesis
chapter 7 verses 1 and 2.
and the Lord said unto Noah Come Thou
and all thy house into the ark for thee
I have seen righteous before me uh in
this generation of every clean Beast
Thou shalt take unto these seven by
sevens the male and his female of the
beasts that are not cleaned by two the
male and his female so God brings the
clean beasts the clean animals into the
Ark by sevens because God's plan is to
allow man to not only is never going to
sacrifice some of these animals but he's
also going to consume some of these
animals and then secondly God isn't
going to overrule the consequences of
sin and evil so God has brought a flood
upon the Earth he's not going to cause a
miracle to happen in order for
vegetation to grow up in order for man
to eat the healthiest food again and
live all these you know centuries again
and then have wickedness pile up again
and we can say well if God started all
over with Noah you know maybe there
wasn't going to be as much wickedness
well we know that's not the case I mean
Noah was a short time later drunk in his
tent you know and his sons one of his
sons you know then was just perverse in
the way he related to that and so we
have the whole cycle beginning again and
at that time we're probably saying you
know it's a good thing that God actually
said you know we're not going to let men
live as long so definitely God had a
purpose and definitely God doesn't
always overrule the consequences of our
sins good answer
Shelley this is your four-minute
question does revelation 20 verse 10 say
that the devil false prophet and the
beasts are tormented in the lake of fire
and brimstone day and night forever and
ever is this a different place in
Revelation 20 verses 11 to 14 and this
is from Charlie in Illinois
Charlie let's read Revelation 20 verses
10 through 15 where the devil the false
prophet and the Beast end up are the
same Lake of Fire we're going to see
this just a second Revelation 20 10-15
the devil who deceived them was cast
into the Lake of Fire in Brimstone where
the Beast and the false prophet are and
they were tormented day and night
forever and ever then I saw a great
white throne in him who sat on it this
is that white Throne judgment from whose
face the earth and the heaven float away
and there was found no place for them
and I saw the dead small and great these
are the ones who came up in the second
resurrection of the wicked and they're
standing before God the books were
opened another book was opened which was
the book The Life and the dead were
judged according to the works by the
things where which were written in the
books the sea gave up those who were in
it death and Hades were delivered up the
the Dead who were in them and they were
judged each one according to his work
now listen then death and Hades were
cast into the Lake of Fire this is the
same Lake of Fire of Brimstone this is
the second death is what verse 14 says
four times in Revelations it talks about
the second death the utter perishing and
anyone not found written in the Book of
Life was cast into the Lake of Fire he
goes on in context in Revelation 28 the
Cowardly unbelieving abominable murders
sexually immoral Sorcerers idolaters all
Liars have their part in the lake same
Lake which burns with fire and brimstone
which is the second death now let me
explain something very quickly
there is a word in the Greek and it is
ionius and what that word is it's used
for Everlasting Eternal forever
this word is a relative term it gains
its meaning from the person or the
object it is describing so it is subject
to it relates to whoever it's describing
so used in relationship with God when
this word is used forever
Eternal Everlasting it reflects an
infinite existence because God is
infinite so anytime you see Everlasting
Eternal or forever
relating to God because he's infinite
those words reflect that infinite
existence but the sharp contrast is this
when that word is used forever
Everlasting in relationship to Mortal
Humanity or a subject of a perishable
thing then it is talking only about as
long as the person or thing exists so
Jude 7 Sodom and Gomorrah were set forth
as an example of
Eternal fire are they still on fire
today no
Eternal there meant the fire did not go
out until it was it wasn't quenched
until
it accomplished its purpose and they
just absolutely burned up so the second
death
Psalm 37 20 says the Wicked Will perish
into smoke they vanish your way and
Malachi 4 1-3 says the day is coming
burning like an oven when the wicked
will burn up they'll be stubble leaves
them neither root nor branch and their
ashes under the soul of our feet so the
Lake of Fire where the devil and the
false prophet and the Beast are thrown
same Lake Fire Brimstone at that where
the other Wicked and they'll all burn up
and perish amen good answer
I want to share once again our contact
information how to get your questions to
3abn number one if you'd like to text
them in
[Music]
618-228-3975 once again
618-228-3975 if you'd like to email them
in to us it's Bible QA at
3abn.tv that is Bible QA at 3abn TV and
if you'd like to use Instagram at
3abn underscore official once again at
3abn underscore official
okay Daniel
where in the Bible does it say that
polygamy is wrong and this is from John
in New York all right you're not going
to find a single text that says polygamy
is wrong in the same way that you won't
find a single text that says smoking
marijuana is wrong but we look for
biblical principles and I'm going to
jump right into what Jesus says when he
is being questioned about marriage and
divorce in Matthew Chapter 19 Verse 4
and 5 it says and he said to them have
you not read and so Jesus now endorsing
the words of scripture that he is
inspired that he who made them at the
beginning made them male and female and
said for this reason a man shall leave
his father and mother and be joined to
his wife and the two
shall become one flesh and so Jesus here
is simply confirming the truth that we
see already in the Garden of Eden that
God's original plan was that there is a
man and a woman in marriage the two
becoming one flesh
and so where do we first find polygamy
it's introduced in Genesis chapter 4 19
to 24. Genesis 4 and 5 give a contrast
of two families the family of the family
line of those who are following God in
the family line of those who don't and
so we see lamech in Genesis 4 the
seventh generation and he of those who
are rejecting God and he engages both in
polygamy and rejoicing in Murder
a couple of other principles in the New
Testament First Corinthians chapter 7 39
and you can also see the same thing in
Romans chapter 7. it says a wife is
bound by law by law as long as her
husband lives but if her husband dies
she's at Liberty to be married to whom
she wishes only in the Lord so there's
no liberty for adding an extra spouse
unless your spouse has died
uh their instructions for spiritual
leaders given to the church I think of
Deuteronomy chapter 17 where there are
instructions given to the King as a
representative of God's people and it
says do not gather for yourselves
multiply many wives first Timothy
chapter 3 verse 2 and 12 says that a
bishop or overseer should be blameless a
husband of one wife and then again a
deacon in verse 12 a husband of one wife
and we find that principle in Titus
Chapter 1 Verse 6 as well
and practically speaking when we look at
the fruits of polygamy not to say that
monogamous marriages cannot suffer under
the power of sin as well but we see that
the role of fathers is much more
difficult under polygamy not enough a
time or ability to influence the
children as is needed and then we see
Power struggles Illustrated in the lives
of Abraham and Jacob because of polygamy
and polygamy also weakens the voice of
women and God certainly wants to protect
each person each partner in the marriage
so why did God allow polygamy Jesus
tells us right there again in chapter 19
of of Matthew says that God allowed it
because of the hardness of their hearts
but it was not his plan in the beginning
that's not polygamy that's divorce all
right and so why would God permit it
sometimes because of the hardness of the
hearts
amen amen
James
this is your four-minute questions oh
giddy my husband just passed away and I
would really like to know if we will be
a married couple when we come back to
the new Earth and this is Delilah
intensive in Pennsylvania well Delilah
in Pennsylvania
this is or in Tennessee this is quite a
question my wife and I have talked about
this for years and years and years and I
think I'm finally ready to surrender The
Words of Christ let's read them in the
gospel of Matthew
I didn't put the reference down here so
but I will start with Verse 18 and I'll
get to the reference before we're done
then came he came unto him the Sadducees
which say there is no resurrection and
they asked him saying Master Moses wrote
unto us if a man's brother died and
leave his wife behind and leave no
children that his brother should take
his wife and raise up seed unto his
brother verse 20 now there were seven
Brethren and the first took a wife and
dying left no seed and the second took
her and died neither left any seed and
the third likewise and the Seven had her
and there was no C and last of all the
woman died also and in the resurrection
therefore when they shall rise whose
wife shall she be of them for the seven
had her to wife
and Jesus verse 24 answered and said
unto them
do you not know therefore excuse me do
ye not therefore air because you know
not the scriptures neither the power of
God for when they shall rise from the
dead neither they shall neither marry
nor are given in marriage but are as the
Angels which are in heaven and is
touching the dead they that rise and
they that rise have you not read in the
book of Moses how in the bush God spoke
unto him in saying I am the god of
Abraham the god of Isaac and the god of
Jacob he is not the god of the dead but
the god of the living ye therefore do
greatly Heir so Jesus is doing two
things here first of all he's setting
the Sadducees straight on the
resurrection because they didn't believe
in it they didn't believe in the
resurrection and then he's clarifying
what takes place in the new heavens and
the new Earth after we're resurrected
and he's pretty clear on this I've
struggled with this for many years my
wife has always accepted these words and
said you know what in heaven we're not
going to be married we're going to be
like the Angels we're right we're not
going to be married and I've said well
does that mean you're going to have your
place down there and I'm going to have
my place over here and you'll come over
and visit me sometimes and I'll go over
and visit you sometimes I always said
that with a smile on my face and just
kind of because my wife is very clingy
very connected to me and you know this
idea would kind of rub her wrong because
she likes to be with me now you know
where I go when I travel she likes to be
with me
and so I'm telling you all in new Heaven
and North you're not going to want to be
with me and she her response says well
these are the words of Christ and I
can't imagine being in a situation in
New Heaven in the new Earth being in a
situation for a eternity that wouldn't
make us happier than we are now right
now the happiest place that my wife and
I can be as together we like to be
together I know we don't like to be
separated and I believe that whatever
state of being we're going to be in in
the new Heaven and the new Earth we are
going to be as happy if not happier than
we are right now now if that means being
like the Angels well we don't have this
marriage relationship and these you know
children parent relationships I'm okay
with that I don't fully know but I do
know the word of God seems to be pretty
clear here that our situation is going
to be different than it is right now and
that means to me if I just accept these
words as they read that means to me that
we are going to be in a state of being
that is more applicable to living in the
new Heaven and the new Earth and living
for all eternity more applicable to the
than the to than to the way we live
right now and God knows what we're going
to need to make us the happiest in that
situation so I'm finally settling into
accepting the word of God as it reads I
don't believe we're going to be married
in the new heavens and the new Earth or
have children but I do believe we're
going to be as happy as can be and I do
believe I'm going to know my wife and
she's going to know me and we're going
to be able to hang out together and have
a great time just like we do right now
yeah
aye great answer great answer Shelley
yes your third question why didn't God
destroy Satan and his angels with the
flood when God decided to destroy the
Earth with the flood and start over with
Noah and his family
Satan and his angels were involved and
also to be blamed for the sinfulness of
the then world that God had destroyed
but spared Satan and his angels I don't
understand why this is from Shamil in
South Africa
you know Shamil there's probably a lot
of things that we don't understand that
God does but he says my ways are higher
than your ways my thoughts higher than
your thoughts if we think about this God
could have destroyed Satan when Satan
began trafficking lives against him
calling him unfair God could have in the
very beginning just said all right
that's enough of you
you're out he worked with him he worked
with him Satan convinced a third of the
angels to to join his side and what's
interesting to me
what would you have done if you'd been
God
if if God had destroyed Satan
immediately
that would have the rest of the Angels
the other two-thirds would have been
looking on going oh maybe Satan was
right
maybe he is a dictator see God is not a
dictator and God is concerned about the
rest of the onlookers of the universe
but here's why I don't think he
destroyed him after the flood God does
not need counsel from anyone but there
are several places in the Bible that
indicate that he graciously allows some
of his creative beings to come and offer
counsel let me give you these it's Job 1
6 1 Kings 22 19 Daniel 4 17. it's
talking about this heavenly Council
where these creatures come and and they
tell him what their ideas are on to
establish his will so what I believe
it is quite plausible that once Satan
was kicked out of heaven that they all
got together and decided okay let's give
him a short time to either prove or
disprove what his theory is and I think
that God is morally bound by that
decision
Revelation 12 12 says the devil has come
down to you
having great breath because he knows his
time is short so I think the Heavenly
councils this is Shelley quint's look on
it
have set this time span and it may not
seem so short to us but we've got to
remember to the Lord A Thousand Years
seems as a day but God is
in love
allowing the great conflict
to
work its way out play out so that at the
end of time
you know name 1 9 says that
sin will rise no more once this is all
over once we've seen it all and we
understand the love and mercy of God
when we get to heaven we'll never want
to sin again so it's all part of God's
Plan of Salvation for eternity amen
Guys these are good answers
number four question for you Daniel is
the health message from Ellen G white a
Salvation message do you have to be a
vegan to enter Heaven and this is from a
viewer in New York
let me try to say this as clearly as
possible you will not be kept out of
heaven for eating the wrong food
just in the same way that you cannot get
into heaven by eating the right food for
by Grace we have been saved through
faith and that not of ourselves it is
the gift of God not of Works lest anyone
should boast our Salvation is through a
relationship of Faith with Jesus
so let's settle that part right here and
then we thank God that he has given us
instructions to care for our bodies God
designed our body God designed it to run
a certain way that is ordained by him
and that certain way we can call Natural
laws if you eat or drink certain things
your body is going to obey those natural
laws that God has ordained and we call
them natural laws but since they are
designed by God they are God's laws
ignoring them will damage our bodies it
might damage them slowly or it might
damage them quickly and we are told that
God's laws are holy and just and good
and they are not burdensome God's laws
are intended to be a blessing for us
that leads to light life and health
so is what you eat a Salvation issue
in every decision we have the
opportunity to seek and follow the will
of God rather than our own will
a Christian character is not simply
checking off the ten boxes so that we
can show God that we have earned
salvation but it is submitting every one
of our decisions every single moment of
our life to him saying your will be done
not mine in Proverbs 3 5 and 6 trust in
the Lord with all your heart and lean
not on your own understanding but in all
your ways acknowledge Him to direct your
paths and so then we can say that
whether we eat or drink or whatever we
do since it's directed by God we can do
it all for the glory of God not for the
pleasure of self
if I know God's will for my life whether
it be in one of the Ten Commandments or
how I treat my neighbor or what I do
with the body he has lent to me and I
choose to reject God's will in favor of
my own
well what's at stake here is not simply
an issue of food it's an issue of my
trusting relationship with Jesus
so why does it matter why would God care
what it is that we eat and the truth is
that everything we put into our body is
assimilated into our cells and then what
goes in there feeds our brain it is in
our brain our mind where we make a
decision for Christ where we choose to
trust him and form a Christian Godly
character and so God's laws God's Health
laws are a gift given to us to
strengthen our ability to draw close to
Jesus and to hear his voice the decision
of what to do with my body is not a
separate component some off to the side
optional add-on module of Faith what we
do with our body is a daily spiritual
Battleground where Jesus gives us the
opportunity to say thy will be done not
mine and that is the life of faith and
so then we pray the prayer there in
Philippians 2 13 God please work within
me to Will and to do for your good place
sure amen great answer great answer
Pastor James your fourth question yes
sir there's a verse that I've been
struggling with for a long time we are
taught that God made us out of two parts
Spirit the breath of life and dust from
the ground our body then we become a
living Soul
all from Genesis 2 7 but in first
Thessalonians 5 23 Paul makes it a very
different makes it very difficult for me
to understand he says and I pray God
your Holy Spirit and soul and body be
preserved it looks here like he is
talking about three different parts the
spirit the soul and the body
please help me to understand this and
this is from airling in Sweden all right
erling in Sweden you are correct Paul is
definitely encompassing all three
aspects of who we are you're also
correct that we are body and spirit and
those combined together make a living
soul I like to illustrate this with
electricity and a light you know a light
fixture with a bulb in it and the
electricity that comes through the the
power line to that fixture when the
switch is turned on causes that light
bulb to illumine and we could say that
illumination that light that illumines
is the soul and it is produced with a
combination of the electricity and the
lamp itself the fixture itself those two
coming together create this light and
that's the soul and so the Bible teaches
this from the Old Testament all the way
through the New Testament and then
problems that comes to this place and he
says Ah I want your body and your spirit
and your soul to be blessed well that
would be like saying well I want your
lampshade and your electricity and your
light to be blessed it's really not a
contradiction whatsoever our body is the
dust of the earth it's the physical our
spirit is the life force the energy you
know that sometimes people say you're
the life of the party because you have
this great spirit you know this this
energy that comes out of you and then we
are a living being you know our
character our personality who we are
with the combination of the two and Paul
is simply praying that our bodies and
our spirits and our souls and everything
about us in other words our physical
bodies that the energy the the life
force that we have and who we are in our
person who we are and our character and
personality that all of that he's
praying that all of that would be
blessed and preserved blameless before
God Amen it great that's great
Shelly
yes where Adam and Eve both created on
the sixth day
this is a viewer from Indiana
okay we appreciate your questions you
know it's interesting to me that God had
Moses right two creation accounts the
first account goes through the first six
days when God bra he spoke we see he
created something out of nothing and
then in the that's the Transcendence of
God that he is above our physical
existence but then he comes back and he
has his second account where he gives
the up close and personal existence of
God the imminence of God is described
and we see the details of how he created
mankind but let's go to the first
account to get the answer to your
question in the first account we see God
bra he speaks he he Aces and it was so
and the evening in the morning were the
first State and the evening in the
morning were the second day evening in
the morning were the third fourth fifth
now here we've come to the sixth day
Genesis 1 26 then God said let us make
man in our image according to our
likeness this shows it implies that the
godhead is more than one being let them
have dominion over the sea the fish of
the sea the birds of the air the cattle
over all the Earth over every creeping
thing that creeps on the earth so God
created man in his own image in the
image of God he created him male and
female he created them and God blessed
them said be fruitful and multiply fill
the Earth subdue it have dominion over
the fish of the sea over the birds of
the air over every living thing that
moves and God then goes on as it's going
through here this sums up then God saw
everything that he had made
and indeed it was very good so the
evening and the morning were the sixth
day so when you read the first creation
account we're seeing he's speaking brah
he's creating something out of nothing
but you get to the sixth day and it
doesn't explain how he created Adam and
Eve it just as he created them but it's
very definite that both Adam and Eve
were created on the sixth day then you
get to Genesis chapter 2 the second
account and all of a sudden we go from
this Transcendent God to this imminent
God this up close and personal God and
you find out that God got down in the
dust and he shaped a form and he
breathed into their nostrils the up
close and personal God didn't speak man
into existence he created them and
formed them with his own hands and he
was so close can you imagine Adam
opening his eyes he breathes and hears
this face of love that's just right
there near him it's a beautiful story
came out amen
we've got two minutes and 45 seconds
until we go to a con contact row any
final thoughts that we want to go or
read I love what Shelly was just sharing
you know because the same thing with Eve
he took a rib yeah he put man to sleep
took a rib and probably did the same
thing I also like we shared earlier
about the allowance for sin and for
Satan because you know in Philippians 2
it says every knee will bow and every
tongue will confess so God has been long
suffering with Satan Satan's going to be
one of those needs that bows yes and the
fallen angels are also going to confess
and you know I want to point out
something too about that is some people
think that Satan is omnipresent some
people think that he has immortality
he's a created being he can only be in
one place at one time and he is not
Immortal because the Bible tells us
first Timothy 2 16 that God Alone 4 16
has immortality at this point excuse me
huh 6 16. 6 16. I'll get there but the
so you know in uh I got to tell you
something you know we people are always
saying oh the devil did this to me or
that to me actually
he's got a whole troop I call him the
Unholy Alliance of Satan because we've
got all the two the third of the angels
that came down with him Satan's more I
think the person who's directing them
and makes up and he sends them out but
um
if the devil
were to come to us
as he did to Jesus we have no idea what
Temptations we have no idea no idea
because we haven't seen the full force
of that also like what you were saying
Daniel about the question concerning our
bodies and you were mentioning you know
that God has developed these laws and
they help us in our spiritual
relationship with God like Daniel Daniel
chapter one you know he went back to the
diet that God originally planned for him
the pulse and the water rather than the
Babylonian diet and he was 10 times
wiser with his friends you know they
needed that connectivity with the Lord
and in Daniel chapter 4 God brings King
Nebuchadnezzar to that diet as well
and can we clarify one point because
there are people who will say oh we're
going to do the Daniel Fast we're going
to do 10 days Daniel didn't do this for
just 10 days this was a lifestyle this
was a choice he ate that way always so
it's not something that he he just put
aside the test was for 10 days but
that was wonderful we're going to go to
about a two-minute contact row then
we'll be back it's
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
okay ladies and gentlemen we have a two
minutes left so any final thoughts I
know that Daniel that you had something
that you wanted to add that's right I
wanted to finish talking about Daniel 12
verses and 11 and 12 by taking you to
what Jesus says about it in Matthew
chapter 24 verse 15. he says when you
see the abomination of desolation spoken
of by the Prophet Daniel standing in the
Holy place and then in parentheses
whoever reads let him understand and the
principle here is that Jesus expects us
to be reading the book of Daniel even if
we don't understand it all right now
Jesus says there's wisdom in there for
you and by God's help we will be among
those who are wise we know that wisdom
doesn't come just because we are cunning
enough or we are clever enough to figure
things out that wisdom comes through the
Holy Spirit if any of you lacks wisdom
let him ask of God who gives to all
liberally and without reproach and it
will be given to him so if you don't
understand something keep reading keep
asking amen amen I love that you know
you were talking earlier about that
question concerning you know do we have
to be a vegan to get into heaven and
another thing that came to my mind is
you were talking about that was well
Jesus ate fish
he wasn't a vegan you know and probably
ate the Passover Lamb too so I really I
know that God has made our bodies
temples I'm actually a vegetarian vegan
most of the time and yet I know that
there's this principle that runs through
the Bible that we are saved by grace
through faith I love that and not of
ourselves we are not saved by what we
eat or what we don't eat we are saved by
the grace of God Amen in
I want to thank y'all I mean y'all did
good it just amazes me
I want to thank you for watching and
don't forget that if you have questions
this is your station so send in your
questions we'll be happy to look up the
answers God love you we certainly love
you take care God bless
[Music]
foreign